ciao a tutti trovo assurdo dover fare il
2018 un video di questo tipo assurdo lo
trovo assurdo però vabbè ho pensato dai
facciamo questo sforzo
prendiamo una macchina del tempo e
viaggiamo indietro di cent'anni per
parlare con quelli che sono gli ideatori
di questa pubblicità che sta andando in
giro chiaramente questa campagna due
uomini non fanno una madre hashtag stop
utero in affitto ci sono due uomini
genitore o genitore due genitori uno si
genitore due genitori 1 e c'è questo
bambino che piange su un carrello della
spesa con un codice a barre sul tetto
uscito anche un altro se non sbaglio non
sono uscito a trovare che è l'opposto
due donne non farlo un padre grazie al
cazzo vorrei dire bravi e non so dove
iniziare anche io non voglio spiegare
nemmeno a queste persone come l'uomo che
ti ha dato la vita a volte non riesca
essere un padre come la stessa cosa
possa valere per la donna che ha dato la
vita
io non voglio spiegare a queste persone
come ad oggi sia ancora obsoleto parlare
di mamma e papà nel 2018 la famiglia del
mulino bianco è una roba che non esiste
capita così poche persone che è una
rarità che è la vera minoranza la
famiglia del mulino bianco però è quell
idea che distrugge le famiglie come
l'amore romantico distruggere coppie
quello che vorrei fare io un attimo
analizzare questa pubblicità due uomini
non fanno una madre hashtag stop utero
in affitto
che cazzo c'entrano le due cose insieme
quello che stai dicendo quindi che tu
non appoggi con questa campagna all'uomo
genitorialità però sotto è messo hashtag
sto punto in affitto perché fare un
cartellone contro le famiglie arcobaleno
con di realta stai parlando aiuti
nell'affitto nikole kidman lo ha fatto
l'utero in affitto una cosa da ricchi
partiamo da questo presupposto non è una
cosa da key note l'affitto costa un
boato e sapete qual è uno dei motivi
a parte i costi esorbitanti che deve
affrontare in generale per poterselo
permettere
il motivo è che in italia non è legale
quindi di che cazzo stiamo parlando tu
puoi stoppare qualcosa che sta bene
effettivamente posso dirti stop al
razzismo perché una realtà all'interno
dell'italia stop al maschilismo stop
alla cipolla nella carbonara ti posso
dire perché una cosa che viene ma stop
all'utero in affitto che cazzo c'entra
se in italia non è legale è come se tu
che sia sulla campagna nella quale dc
stop
l'ananas sulla pizza ma nessuno mette
l'ananas sulla pizza in italia e ti
troncano le mani se ci provi e se esiste
una pizzeria che lo sa bene ancora
esplosa stop utero in affitto ma anche
di che partendo dall'assunto quindi che
questo hashtag con quella frase non
c'entrano un emerita fava
l'altra faccia della medaglia però è
questa bella frase che due uomini non
fanno una madre due donne non fanno un
padre
credo che questa frase sia un insulto
non tanto ai genitori ai figli chi l'ha
ideata non ha pensato magari a le
conseguenze dell'affermazione due uomini
non fanno una madre perché fidatevi che
se ci avessero pensato avrebbero deciso
quel giorno di andare a giocare a ping
pong cioè che cosa vuoi dire che un
bambino che non cresce senza madre o
senza padre è un bambino in completo è
un bambino di serie b due uomini fanno
una madre
vuol dire che tu hai bisogno di una
madre per poter crescere due donne non
fanno un padre vuol dire che tu hai
bisogno di un padre per crescere ma
lasciatemi dire una cosa
uscite dal mondo degli unicorni fatati
del cazzo e mettete un piede nella vita
reale perché un sacco di persone non
hanno una mamma o non hanno padre perché
perché la vita e bastardo e venire a
dire che nei cugini siccome hanno perso
il loro padre dieci anni fa e che quindi
hanno avuto una mamma soltanto sono dei
figli di serie b sono cresciuti
sicuramente con un sacco di scompensi
per me è abominevole mia zia fatto da
madre da padre da tutto quanto è l'unica
cosa veramente drammatica è che mio zio
era un padre meraviglioso ma esistono
donne che rimangono da sole perché i
padri dei loro figli si danno e in quel
caso di cosa parliamo
dobbiamo piangere l'uomo che ti ha dato
la vita perché perché ha deciso di
voltargli le spalle e quindi tu rimarrai
per sempre un [ __ ] senza una figura
paterna ma
cazzo stiamo parlando da fuori esistono
figli di divorziati che non vedono mai
padri perché perché spesso la legge non
permette ai padri di stare presso i
figli quanto vorrebbero ma vengono
decisi dei giorni di quel weekend
ok per tutta la restante parte della
settimana o stanno con i nonni
oppure sono accuditi e dal compagno
della madre io conosco un sacco di
ragazzini che vivono una realtà di
questo tipo ragazzini che sin da piccoli
hanno vissuto il divorzio dei genitori e
che quindi mi vengono a dire se è così
io ho due padre e una madre perché
perché mi ha proprio il vero che mio
papà ma non lo vedo mai mi cresce il
compagno di mia madre ma di che stiamo
parlando
ma come ti permette di dire una cosa
così e bambini che stanno in
orfanotrofio bambini serie z sarebbe
bellissimo poter avere la mamma il papà
ma sarebbe bellissimo avere 20 mamma
eventi papa che ti vogliono bene ognuno
dal quale andare in caso di necessità ma
anche quando c'è la mamma il papà volte
non sa con chi cazzo parlare perché
hanno troppi problemi loro per poterti
stare dietro che stiamo parlando ragazze
dare la vita non è sinonimo di
prendersene cura
e parlando di figli voglio parlare del
bambino presente su questa pubblicità
parliamo in un secondo sulla pubblicità
è presente un bambino con un codice a
barre dentro un carrello che piange qual
è il messaggio i bambini non sono
prodotti i bambini non si comprano e non
si vendono come se fossero oggetti
giusto non si deve scegliere per loro
per questo bambino in particolare nella
pubblicità un giorno sarà un uomo ed è
stato scelto che questo bambino mandasse
un messaggio il quale magari con un
futuro non crederà nemmeno avete usato
le sue lacrime per farci credere che
stesse ma lì in quella situazione sfido
io ho messo su un carrello con un codice
a barre sul petto per vendere una vostra
idea anche io avrei più alto pur di
uscire da quella pubblicità messo in un
carrello con un codice a barre sul tetto
per farci credere e farci capire che i
bambini non sono un prodotto che si può
comprare che si può vendere
beh signori pro famiglia e probità quel
codice a barre su quel bambino pur di
vendere unite del cazzo ci avete messo i